[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الاتفاق او الاعلان عن الاتفاق
بين السعوديه وايران بوساطه صينيه
لاستئناف العلاقات بين البلدين بعد قطيعه
دامت سبع سنوات احدث مواقف متباينه لدى
النظام الايراني بين مرحبه واخرى متفاجئه
بل وانعكس على اعلامه الذي تحدث عن حاله
من الصدمه والارباك في الشارع الايراني
وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير
عبداللهيان وصف المحادثات مع السعوديه
بانها كانت معقده وصعبه ولكن المهم انها
ادت الى نتيجه واضحه وفق قوله واكد عبد
الحيان على ان الاتفاق لاعاده تفعيل
العلاقه الدبلوماسيه ليس موجهها ضد اي
دوله وان الاتفاق يخدم مصالح البلدين ويصب
في صالح دول المنطقه في حين صرح المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني بانف
العلاقات السياسيه بين ايران والسعوديه
اظهرا فاعليه ونجاح الحل الدبلوماسي
لتسويه الخ مضيفا ان هذا تطور الدبلوماسي
المهم يمكن ان تكون له اثار ونتائج
ايجابيه في العلاقات الاقليميه بين الدول
الموجوده في هذه الجغرافيا المشتركه اما
عضو لجنه السياسه الخارجيه في البرلمان
الايراني في تحسين مالكي فقد صرح بانه
كلما اقتربت بلاده من دول الجوار والمنطقه
اكثر فانه يمكن حل مشكلتنا كما قال
بمساعدتهم بينما اعتبر مستشار المرشد
الايراني يحيى الصفوي ان الاتفاق يعد
زلزالا في الساحه السياسيه املا في ان
تتحرك المنطقه نحو الامن والسلام
المستدامه بعد هذا الاتفاق
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من الشرقيه
كامل الخطيه الكاتب والبحث في السعوديه
اهلا بك من بيروت مصطفى فحص الكاتب الصحفي
اهلا بك من دبي مسعود الفاك الباحث في
الايراني اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام اسمحوا لي
ان ابدا من بيروت معك استاذ مصطفى استاذ
مصطفى لفهم هذه العلاقه وهذه المقاربه بما
يخص النظام الايراني بمعنى اذا ما حاولنا
تصنيف النظام الايراني وقربناه بمفهومين
مفهوم الدوله كما تؤطرها ويؤطرها المجتمع
الدولي ويعرفها ومفهوم الثوره التي بنت
عليها ايران سياستها اين هو النظام
الايراني من هذين المفهومين
اذا كان السؤال يتعلق مفهوم تفسير النظام
الايراني من الاتفاق الصيني يعني اكمل
سؤالك فاعتقد ان هذا الاتفاق جرى مع مفهوم
الثوره
بمعنى ما يطلق على انفسهم النظام اي
الثوره هم نوقعوا هذا الاتفاق لان ما كنا
نعتبرها الدوله لا تستطيع ان تنجز هكذا
اتفاق كما يقال دائما ان السلم يحتاج الى
يمينين فقط تحقق قد تحقق وتحقق هذا
لان في ايران انتهت انتهت معنى الطبيعتين
في النظام الايراني الان هناك طبيعه واحده
طبيعه حزب الله هي ممكن تسميتها
بالجمهوريه المرشد الثاني او المرحله
الخامنائيه اي الحزب الله هي التي توحدت
طبيعه النظام ضمن الطبيعه التي يريدها
السيد علي خمني الان الحكومه وراس وراس
الحكومه بمعنى رئيس الجمهوريه اجهزه
الدوله اجهزه النظام او الثوره هو ضمن
اداره واحده اي انها متجانسه هذا التجانس
يمكن القياده النظام الايراني من تحقيق
هذا الاتفاق ولكن تحقيق هذا الاتفاق هنا
نعود الى طبيعه اخرى يحتاج الى طبيعه
الدوله وليس الى طبيعه الثوره اذا هنا نحن
امام هذه المعضله الثوره بمعناها بمعنى
مكتب خامنائي بمعنى الحرس الثوري بمعنى
القياده الراديكاليه اجمعت على هذا
الاتفاق ولكن لكي تطبقه عليها ان تطبقه
بطبيعه الدوله كدوله هنا الصراع الايراني
الداخلي لذلك حتى الان بالنسبه لكراقب
الامور مبهمه داخل الايراني واضحه في
الرياض واضحه امام المجتمع الدولي واضح
امام الراي العام العربي والاقليمي
والدولي ولكن الغموض يبقى سيد الموقف في
طهران كيف ترى هذه النقطه استاذه كامل لما
نتحدث عن ان الثوره بقياداتها هي التي
ودفعت بهذا الاتفاق هل تراه معضله كما
وصفه الاستاذ مصطفى ام ان هذا الموضوع
بالعكس قد يمهد لنجاحه بما اننا نتحدث عن
الشق المتشدد الذي دفع بهكذا خطوه
انا طبعا لا ارى موضوع
الثوره والدوله انه في ايران الدوله في حد
ذاتها تمر يعني
من يوم نجاح الثوره الى الان الدوله تعاني
المعضله وجودي شرعيه الدوله مستمده من
فكره غيبيه اساسا
الثوره الثوره هي اداه
لتحقيق نقود لايران في الاقليم
وايجاد اوراق ضغط لايران كقوه اقليميه
تشاوم بهالجوار من دون نجاح الثوره
ناظره الدوله طيران علشان
يستطيع الايرانيين يخرجوا من خارج هذا
المازق الوجود انه يتخلصوا من فكره الدوله
القائمه على ولايه سطيف شرعيه وشرعيه
الحاكم لابد ان يكون متوفره لشروق محدده
هي طبعا الشروط مش منذ ان وضعها الخميني
هي لا تزال المحمول بها الى اليوم حدث
عليها حدث عليها التغيرات جدريه من ضمنها
مثلا شرط الشرطه العالميه المرشد وتحول
المرشد مع الوقت لانه يقر ويعترف بانه
وليس لا اعلم
ويعترف منظرها ايضا بانه ولي الامر ولكن
ذلك لا يعني ان على الشيعه التقليديه في
العالم فشرعيه ثلاث لا تزال تتاتى من
كورونا ممثله امام القائد هذه معضله
موجوده في الدوله ذاتها
مو حقيقه انه يعني في دوله في ايران لكنها
الدوله الان اصبحت صالحا الثوره لا مطلقا
لا ارى ذلك اشوف انه ايران ايران في
الدوله ذاتها عندها
طبعا المحاولات المحاولات المحاولات
النزول او المحاولات السلوك مسلك الدوله
هي مش اول مره تحدث في التاريخ ايران
اظن بعض
المشاهدين ربما ايضا الزملاء ضيوف في هذه
الحلقه يتذكرون بان بان ايران كان فيها
مكتب لرعايه وحركات السوريه كان على راسها
مهدي هاشمي الذي اوعد في قضيه ايران كنترا
كان مهدي هاشمي تحت رعايه الشيخ حسام
منتظري وهو الشريك الرئيسي والاكبر
الخميني وكان ايضا فقيه عنده اجازات
اجتهاد لحق الاستنباط والاجتهاد وكاتب
ربما
يعني الارض النظري الان فيما يتعلق بفقه
الدوله ولا يستطيع منذ نجاح الثوره الان
هو ما كتب هو الكتاب الذي كتب حسين منتظر
حسين منتظر حسين منتظر بعد ازاحه مهدي
هاشمي ايضا نقود حسين متضربه بدات الى
انفسنا الى ان معزول من جميع مناصبه
ومحروم من جميع وسائل القوه والتاثير داخل
الدوله
انه صعدت في ايران صعدت قوه
عندها ميل نحو تهذيب سلوك الايراني تقليل
الجموح الثوري في المنطقه ومحاوله تصالح
مع الاقليم من ضمنهم الاب والابرز فيهم
وفعلا الى حد كبير
تحسنت علاقته في دول الجوار على وجه ولكن
محاوله تهذيب السلوك الايراني ادى الى
صراع داخلي وادى الى ازمه حقيقيه فداخل
الايراني وحضرتك تعرف بينما حصل فيما قبل
وتتنبا بانه قادر ان يحدث مستقبلا اسمح لي
ان اسال الاستاذ مسعود بخصوص هذه النقطه
استاذ مسعود هل تعتقد باننا امام صراع في
داخل الايراني بين مفهوم القيادات لهذا
القيادات الثوريه او من حمل على كتفه
مفهوم الثوره بشكلها التقليدي فداخل
الايراني وبين ما يجب ان تكون عليه الدوله
الايرانيه حتى تنجح هذه الاتفاقيه
تحياتي لك ولضيوفك الكرام والمشاهدين
الاعزاء
سؤال مهم
وهذا مرتبط بشكل موضوعي
بالاتفاق بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وايران
عندما انتهت حكومه حسن روحاني
وجاءت حكومه
رئيسي ابراهيم رئيسي
النظام في داخل ايران السلطه في داخل
ايران اصبحت من لون واحد سابقا كان هناك
التيار الاصلاحي والتيار المعتدل معه
والتيار
المتشدد والتيار المحافظ الان السلطه كل
مفاصل السلطه بيد تيار واحد لا توجد هذه
الثنائيه كما كانت في السابق لذا
انتقل الصراع من
اصلاح
معتدل ومتشدد محافظ الى
الصراع في داخل البيت الواحد الصراع الى
داخل المؤسسات الدوله في الداخليه ايران
وهذا الصراع في واقع في نفس الوقت للحفاظ
على النظام حتى لا ينهار هذا النظام
اثبتت حكومه
ابراهيم رئيسي بانها لن تستطع على الصعيد
الخارجي ان تبني علاقات وتمدد جسور
المطلوبه نظرا لظروف ايران وخضوعها
للعقوبات وعزلتها خاصه بعد تدخلها في حرب
اوكرانيا والموقف الاوروبي الذي يمكن
للقول بانه اقترب من الموقف الامريكي ضد
ايران هذه السياسه الخارجيه الايرانيه
باعتقاد الان يحاول التيار الاخر الذي هو
اقرب الى المرشد ينقذ الوضع عندما يكون
وزير الخارجيه الايراني لا يجيد التحدث
باللغه الانجليزيه لا يجيد التحدث باللغه
العربيه لا يعرف اوليات السياسه الخارجيه
حتى هذا اثر سلبا على علاقات ايران
الخارجيه وايران في هذه
بدات تدفع الكثير والكثير لذا ارادت ان
تخرج من هذا الوضع المفروض عليها اسبابه
الجزء الاكبر داخلي الان في هذه المرحله
لذا وجدت بانه يجب ان تبني علاقات اقليميه
والعلاقات الاقليميه هو السد المنيع امام
هذه العلاقات الاقليميه علاقاتها المتوتر
مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه لذا لجات
ايران الى هذه الاتفاقيه ولجات الى
محاولات ولكن سيد مصطفى هل تعتقد فعليا
بانه هناك نيه حقيقيه في داخل الايراني
للدفع بنجاح هذه الاتفاقية ومنذ قليل
حضرتك تحدثت عن معضله داخل الايراني وعن
هذا الانقسام او على الاقل هذه الاختلافات
هل ترى بانه
هذه المعضله قادره ان تفسد ما تم الاتفاق
عليه الى اي مدى هذه المعضله او هذه اللي
هو بين الشقين قادره ان تؤثر على مسار هذه
الاتفاقيه
سؤالك ساجيب سابدا من حيث انتهى استاذي
مسعود
عندما تكلم عن الطبيعه الواحده وان من
يحكم ايران الان وان الصراع انتقل الى
داخل البيت الواحد فعليا نعم هي حقيقه نحن
الان امام مواجهه البيت الواحد او قياده
خامنتي باجنحتها والجناح الاساسي منه هو
الحرس الثوري لدى الحرس الثوري جناح اخر
هو فيلق القدس
الان السؤال يطرح نفسه ماذا يفعل فيلق
القدس بعد هذا الاتفاق هو معطل في كل
المستعمرات الايرانيه التي فاثبت فيها
العراق
اليمنقشه باكثر تفاصيل ولكن في الجزء
الثاني ولكن اكمل فكرتك وخليها مدخل لما
سننقل
اوكي خلاص التزم مش محوسع فيها اذا
كمان لا اكمل من عند الاستاذ مسعود النظام
الطبيعه الواحده الان ولديها ازمه حقيقيه
في المرحله الانتقاليه من سيخلف خامنا
الموت المفاجئ للمرشد هل من هو من هي كيف
ستكون طبيعه المرشد بعد مقتل قاسم سليماني
خرجت كل الصراعات التي كان يضبطها قاسم
سليماني داخل هذا البيت
الاتفاق جاء اما ان يخفف الضغوط فيما
بينها ويفسح مجال لنقاش ايراني داخلي حول
المرحله الانتقاليه في ايران وهذا له
ايجابيات وله خسائر جانبيه في الطبيعه
الايرانيه قد تكون كبيره لان هناك فعليا
داخليا داخل اروقه الحرس وداخل ارقد رجال
الدين الراديدين او الاكليروس المتشدد في
ايران الذي ينتج
ولايه سلطه ولايه الفقيه ايضا هو يفقد
مبررات
لان هذه الطبيعه هي فاقده للمشروعيه
الشعبيه ونحن نرى ماذا يجري في ايران من
خلال الانتخابات ومن خلال الشارع ومن خلال
عقده الحجاب والان يفقد مشروعيته الثوريه
في الخارج تعطل تعطل هذا النظام هذا سيفجر
الداخل من سيمضي مع الغطاء الذي يؤمنه
المرشد لهذا الاتفاق وكيف ستخرج هذه
الاعتراضات من الداخل وعندما تخرج من داخل
البيت الواحد من الطبيعي ان تكشف عن
انشقاقات كبيره
ستؤدي الى تعطيل ما فكر به المرشد وهو جزء
منه المرحله
الى اي مدى هناك قدره على احتواء كذلك
يعني في جزئين هل ستعطل مسار او يمكن
احتوائها ام لا هذا سيكون محل نقاشنا بعد
قليل فضله بالبقاء معي ضيوف الكرام